over the past few weeks apple's new m1
max have been impressing not only apple
fans
but also people who've been using
windows computers for years
with the game changing battery life
being the main advantage so far
linus tech tips finally gave the m1
macbooks an in-depth review
and in their battery life test the m1
13-inch macbook pro
managed to get over 20 hours of battery
life
while the latest dell xps 13 got just
over
12 hours that's an 8 hour difference
and on top of that the m1 is actually
faster
cooler and quieter so to everyone's
surprise
linus actually recommended both the
macbook
air and the pro despite his dumpster
fire of an announcement video
but i don't blame him because even i
didn't expect
rosetta x86 app translation to work
so incredibly well one thing's for sure
though the m1 max
definitely have his curiosity but next
year's
m1x 16-inch macbook pro
will have his attention in this video
i'm gonna take a look at the leaks
surrounding that upcoming 16-inch
macbook
and i'll break down the changes we
should realistically
expect including the performance jump
with the new m1x chip so let's get
started
from all of the leaks we've been seeing
over the past few months
there are two things that we absolutely
know will happen for sure
the 16-inch pro will come with a new
mini led display
and it's going to come with a more
powerful m series apple silicon chip
which i personally think will be called
the m1x chip but before i get into both
of those features
i want to talk about something that we
don't really know for sure
just yet and this one thing will change
everything else
way back in july the reliable apple
analyst
minshikuo said that the first r mac
would be a 13.3 inch macbook pro
shipping before the end of the year
without any sort of design
changes and he was right within that
same investor note
he claimed that two redesigned macbook
pros would be coming
in 2021 including both a 14
and 16 inch macbook pro way later in
december
he said that these two macbook pros will
have mini led displays
and they'll have an all new form factor
design
now the big question is what does all
new form factor mean
in reality the current 16-inch macbook
pro only came out in 2019
with thinner bezels it already came with
updated studio quality microphones
and a new six speaker system how much
more
could they change it well apple could go
all out
and drastically update the design
potentially changing the display
to have rounded corners just like an
ipad pro
and that might actually make sense since
mac os big sur
now features rounded windows or for
example
they could change the macbook exterior
into a flat slab of metal
like the ipad pro but that would require
the body itself
to get thinner or else it's going to
look way too thick
and how could they possibly do that well
if you think about it
the switch to an all-in-one apple
silicon chip
means that the logic board no longer
needs to be as large
just look at the inside of the new m1
mac mini
the logic board is hilariously small the
power supply
has been completely unchanged and it's
overkill for the m1 chip
the fan is also overkill because it
rarely ever spins up
so in reality apple can shrink down all
of those components
on the 16 macbook pro leaving much more
room
for everything else including the
battery pack
so realistically apple could and should
completely redesign the form factor to
take advantage of the space savings
that they can get with the new chips
therefore making the body thinner
on top of that they don't even need to
keep the same
100 watt hour battery pack because of
how little power
these new apple silicon chips take that
100 watt hour battery pack is 71.82
percent larger
than the one in the 13 inch m1 macbook
pro
and based on linus review the m1 pro
got over 20 hours of battery life
so even if you factor in the higher
resolution and display
size of the 16 inch model the battery
life is going to be insane
if apple keeps the 100 watt hour battery
pack
like potentially 30 hours or more
of battery life and here's something
very interesting
the battery in the 13 inch m1 macbook
pro
is only 16.6 percent larger
than the battery pack in the 13-inch
macbook air
but somehow it was able to get an extra
seven hours of battery life in linus's
test
so imagine how much battery life you'll
get
on top of the 13 inch pro from a 71.82
larger battery and the six inch pro now
i know that there are more
factors than that so let's get into the
new mini led display
based on testing done by light science
and applications
mini led consumes less power
than oled and based on testing done by
notebook check
oled should generally consume less power
than
lcd unless you're constantly viewing
over 50
white on your display so in most cases
the new mini led display will help save
battery life on the new 16 inch macbook
pro
on top of the gains from the larger
battery
so realistically apple could easily
shrink down the battery
and make the 16-inch macbook pro thinner
overall
now if you're not familiar with mini led
technology
let me explain how it works for starters
it still uses an lcd panel
which is safe from the burn-in issues
that come with oled displays
the main difference is that instead of
using one huge
led backlight like on an lcd display
mini led
uses hundreds or thousands of small led
backlights
that can be locally controlled and
completely turned off
when displaying black this leads to
excellent contrast
colors and dynamic range similar to an
oled display
this is actually exactly how apple's pro
display xdr
works the only reason it's not called
a mini led display is because the leds
aren't small enough to be technically
called mini because of the huge
32 inch display size now one of the
other benefits of mini led
is that the entire display is actually
thinner
than an lcd display because of that
apple could easily upgrade the webcam to
a 1080p
webcam especially if they're already
gonna redesign the body
or there's even a chance that apple
could go all
out and use the extra space to add face
id
and believe it or not 9-5 mac discovered
mentions of face id in one of the betas
of mac os big sur
so this could actually be happening now
the last thing i want to talk about
is the new m1x chip that will be going
into the 16 inch pro
way back in april it was reported that
apple will be using a 12
core 5 nanometer arm chip in a 2021
macbook and since the m1 has 8 cores
it totally makes sense that the m1x will
be
that 12 core chip that they were talking
about basically
it's gonna have the same four efficiency
cores but it's gonna have
double the amount of performance course
so before i get into the performance
numbers that we should expect
i wanna touch on the battery life for
the most basic
and simple tasks the 16 inch will still
be using
the four efficiency cores to run them
and for watching videos
that is actually handled by the hardware
video decoders
so battery consumption won't go up at
all
and that's how we could potentially see
a 30 hour
battery life figure but in terms of
performance tasks
we can actually calculate the
performance usage
based on the m1 chip's power consumption
under full sustained load
in cinebench r23 the m1 used a total of
14.3 watts
with 13 watts used by the ford
performance cores
and just 1.3 watts used by the
efficiency course
so if the 16 inch gets a 12 core m1x
chip
we can double the power usage of the
four performance cores
and end up with a total of 27.3 watts
under full load and then if we compare
that number
to the power usage of the current intel
i9
16 inch pro it's almost two times more
efficient which is mind-blowing but wait
it gets a whole lot better when we begin
to estimate the performance of the m1x
16-inch macbook pro the current m1 chip
managed to get a score of 7 700 in
cinebench r23
so let's try to break that score down
the four efficiency cores used 1.3 watts
of power
which is about 10 of the power of the
four high performance cores
so if we take the simple route of
dividing that 7700 score in cinebench
by 10 we end up with 700 of that score
coming from the efficiency course and 7
000
from the performance course so if we
assume that the 16 inch pro will get
eight performance cores
that are not gonna throttle because of
efficiency
and the larger cooling system we should
be getting a total score
of 14 700 and cinebench r23
which basically outperforms the 12
core mac pro and that is just insane
that level of performance in a base
16-inch macbook pro
is absolutely unheard of and it's gonna
happen
while using less battery than before and
then if we take a look at the graphics
side
we're expecting the m1x to come packing
a 16 core
gpu so if we double the geek mesh 5
metal score
we got with the m1's 8 core gpu we end
up with around
45 000 points in metal that means that
the m1x's integrated graphics
is going to outperform the absolute best
5600m graphics in the current 16 inch
macbook pro
and if you didn't already know that's
currently
an 800 upgrade option but keep in mind
that the m1x ship will be coming
into the base model 16-inch macbook pro
so if we compare that to the base intel
model
you'll be getting almost double the
graphics performance
and all of that is just looking at raw
performance
if you factor in optimization and
efficiency improvements
from the new unified architecture the
performance is going to be
absolutely insane for example the
current m1 chip
already outperforms the 12 core mac pro
in xcode programming so imagine
the m1x basically what i'm trying to
tell you
is that the 16 inch m1x macbook pro
is gonna blow people's minds it's not
only going to cause
a massive wave of windows laptop users
to switch to the mac but it's literally
going to put the entire computing
industry
into a panic there's going to be a gold
rush of laptop manufacturers
switching to arm-based chips and we'll
start to see announcements
from intel and amd saying that they're
working on
arm chips of their own that are gonna be
going into thin and light laptops
so basically the six inch pro will blow
your mind
and if you're interested in spending
twenty four hundred dollars or more
and you're willing to wait up to half a
year then i would definitely wait
for the m1x pro if this video was
helpful go ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the next video
you